un autre fait ses 10 ans cette année
c'est l'événement national tous au
compost plusieurs animations et
activités sont proposées dans les
Yvelines jusqu'au 9 avril pour en parler
avec nous Matthieu Liot le référent du
site des peupliers pour l'association
plaisir en transition alors Mathieu Liot
quel est l'objectif de cet événement
national tous au compost sensibiliser au
compostage je suppose voilà en gros donc
déjà merci
donc oui le but de cet événement
forcément c'est une sensibilisation
large du public au compostage et aux
solutions
de tri qui des bio déchets des tri des
qui vont qui vont devenir enfin qui vont
pas devenir obligatoire dans un premier
temps mais qui vont être forcément
fortement recommandé
dans un premier temps et après tant de
revers une obligation ça doit devenir de
plus en plus nécessaire
qui sont des déchets organiques et des
déchets compostables donc le et ce sont
des déchets lourds parce que
qui contiennent 80% d'eau en moyenne
donc donc forcément ils sont compliqués
à compliquer à traiter coûteux à traiter
et donc c'est on brûle de l'eau en fait
en permanence donc c'est c'est quand on
le dit comme ça on se dit c'est ridicule
voilà donc c'est vraiment développer des
solutions de terrain au plus proche des
gens réussir à expliquer que c'est pas
si compliqué que ça c'est pas il y a pas
tant de nuisances que ça
il y a pas de nuisances en fait si c'est
bien géré et c'est proposer des
solutions accompagnées voilà pour pour
que ça se passe bien et qu'on aille
et d'ailleurs Céline Guillaume je vous
pose la question est-ce que vous êtes
familier du coup avec cette notion le
compostage est-ce que vous en avez déjà
fait
moi pas beaucoup hein
habiter encore chez mes parents avec un
jardin à des poules on a toujours eu
l'habitude de garder les déchets pour le
pour le jardin par contre c'est vrai que
des personnes qui habitent en
appartement Résidence qui ont pas
forcément ce privilège là je comprends
que c'est un peu plus compliqué on ne se
pose pas forcément la question de jeter
ses bananes dans le compost ou dans le
Back normal c'est un peu plus compliqué
mais il me semble qu'il y a quand même
des composteurs qu'on peut enfin qui
existent en appartement il y a des
composts en les appartements aujourd'hui
en fait on
a des solutions pour tous les
environnements en appartement vous
pouvez avoir des lombrics composteur
donc c'est c'est la même chose qu'un
composteur de jardin sauf que c'est dans
une boîte fermée forcément pour pas que
les vermigres partout mais qui sont
c'est un petit peu technique ça ça prend
assez facilement voilà il y a quelques
choses de base à connaître mais après ça
se passe assez bien et ça permet de
d'éliminer
tout ce qui est tout ce qui est tout ce
qui est épluchures en fait tout ce qui
peut être éliminé
alors événement revenons un petit peu à
tous au compost quel est le programme
avec l'association plaisir en transition
il y a un compost tour il me semble donc
alors l'association plaisir entre
mission c'est une association de plaisir
qui qui organise différents événements
sur sur tout ce qui est sujet de la
transition écologique moi je fais partie
dans cette association là d'un jardin
partagé qu'on a créé il y a deux ans
maintenant donc jardin des peupliers
dans lequel on a fait implanter un
composteur il y a deux ans et dont je
suis référent et dans ce cadre là depuis
son implantation il y a d'autres sites
qui se sont implantés donc dans dans ce
cadre là sur l'événement tous au compost
j'ai eu l'idée de faire un compost tour
donc de faire un proposer une balade à
vélo sur sur plaisir en fait pour aller
d'un site à l'autre
à la rencontre en fait des référents qui
ont pourra nous expliquer l'historique
de leur site plus ou moins récentes et
surtout les fonctionnements parce que
chaque site et chaque chaque site est
assez contraintes et ses fonctionnements
différents fonctions du lieu où il est
les habitations et les personnes qui
participent vous me disiez tout à
l'heure en un an il y a eu l'ouverture
enfin la création de 4 composts ça fait
un boom le composteur en ce moment c'est
avec l'arrivée de cette loi en janvier
2024 qui vient qui vient qui vient de
règlementer
ce tri ce tri des bio des chefs c'est un
volet c'est le tri des bio déchets donc
ça ça vient
faire prendre conscience en fait que il
y a une nécessité d'avancer sur le sujet
dans vos communes respectives Guillaume
Céline
est-ce qu'il y a de plus en plus de
compost qui émergent dans la dans la
ville pour permettre aux citoyens de se
familiariser avec cette pratique
oui alors du côté de maison je crois
qu'on a bien des bacs communs de compost
mais je pense qu'on peut toujours faire
plus à ce niveau là vous pensez
que toien et les agglomérations sont
prêtes pour pour ce passage en janvier
2024 alors les citoyens sont pas tous
prêts il y a encore des encore des
réticences les agglomérations sont pas
toutes prêtes il y a encore des enfin il
y a beaucoup de retard en fait
il y a des agglomérations qui sont plus
ou moins avancées mais tout le monde a
du retard parce que cette loi vient
vraiment mettre un coup d'accélérateur
au processus et aux besoins en fait
c'est
et bien merci beaucoup Mathieu Liot
d'être venu en plateau avec nous pour
nous parler de tous au compost pour
rappel l'événement se déroule jusqu'au 9
avril à Plaisir l'association plaisir en
transition propose un compost tour à
vélo pour découvrir les sites de
compostage pour connaître les activités
près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet tous au
compost point fr